thank you
[Music]
are you guys familiar with the speed of
light Bart take it away
[Laughter]
what about the speed of light you're the
Science Guy take it away I do know that
speed of light and the language of
science is represented by the letter c
so you've never seen equations and that
you see it that's to represent the speed
of light that's not true
um so what we're trying to talk about
right now is how
the speed of light is the speed at which
light travels yeah oh which is crazy
letter C yes damn I didn't know light
even [ __ ] has wheels
sometimes I really hate the show
[Laughter]
there's a law there's a law to our
universe that we believe right is a
prevailing law that limits how quickly
information can travel through empty
space aka the speed of light which tops
out at 186 000 miles per second yes
that's the fastest that's the fastest
you can you can go in fact it has been
fear well it there they believe that if
a human craft was over to go as fast as
the speed of lighter while I was
approaching the speed of light it would
be forced to slow down
so as not to break that law almost like
it would like turn into like slow motion
is that light light won't allow that
[ __ ]
like not not in our house it's like the
back
I literally don't know I mean because
you just it just said if it tries to
it's such a good question it's light
police yes I don't know oh got you okay
yeah I don't know I think the lighter I
like the light likes to follow rules
because they'll be like if that's what I
was told my speed is I'm not going over
the speed limit right because light
ain't got wheels but it got ears I think
a good way to think about it is like so
generally in physics they go um like
gravity pulls at a rate of like 10
meters 9.8 meters per second or 10 meter
10 meters squared right generally but
obviously there's [ __ ] aerodynamics
and [ __ ] like that and like the
thickness of the air it goes into it but
in theory if you drop something from
like 50 stories high it'll accelerate up
until that point and then it'll just
stay that speed it'll never go faster
than that because gravity isn't stronger
than that it's exactly 9.8 or whatever
so speed of light whatever that rate is
it'll go it can accelerate up to that
point but when it once it is the speed
of light it'll just stay there it just
turns into a big c yes small C little C
little little okay
big c means [ __ ] that's true that's what
that's what our wives are just wondering
four times what's the full-time work
[Laughter]
photons themselves are are unlikely to
ever break the speed limit right 186 000
miles a second but there are however
features of Light which don't play by
the same rules oh they don't physicists
in the U.S
this has engaged tell me more it's like
I'm in a a middle school science video
the captain lunch class you know after
that like it's really loopy after
getting like six dollars an hour and
lunch to like be like wow to everything
I say the six dollars an hour if this
was middle comedy Unleashed if this is
elementary school after recess I would
have sat down like this
oh yeah you guys remember that
because it's hot as [ __ ] yeah if you're
trying to cool down your back the
nastiest things
I also remember sitting there in my
[ __ ] classes and
going
that was the best dude what's it called
it's called something I don't know what
it's called but we all did this thing
went hella fire
oh please don't tie it up
um
this guy almost triggered too please
don't tie it this is how we do cool
science talks see we're making it more
like wait you guys are like more
relatable yeah way less science so under
certain conditions waves that's a photon
waves made up of groups of photons can
move faster than light researchers have
been playing with the speed limit of
light pulses for a while speeding them
up and even slowing them to a virtual
standstill using methods like cold
Atomic gases refractive crystals Optical
fibers experiments right but
impressively last year researchers from
Lawrence Livermore National Labs in
California and the University of
Rochester New York managed managed to
make photons in a wave move faster than
the speed of light using hot swarms of
charged particles and fine-tuning the
speed of light waves within plasma sorry
they they did it 30 faster speed light
okay which is crazy because it's faster
than the last known barrier exactly oh
that's what it is there's article is
just mind our own business yeah you're
right why do we have to test [ __ ] we
should respect Nature's privacy God's
gonna come after us dude I mean the
Nerds aren't [ __ ] so what else are
they gonna do so do we kill the
scientists and then we as a sacrifice to
God and say like look see we've got them
for questioning you yeah I think we
should do that
we'll stop having floods and [ __ ] dude
it's been raining in L.A in September oh
God so much that's weird September yeah
I think God is a woman now because God
is a vindictive a conniving person
and God doesn't forget anything
[Laughter]
uh so that's it right we we we have
maybe cracked the speed of light but uh
on a subatomic level it's less
impressive people only want to put
people
like you know in baskets in a ship and
then that's what would impress people
and make them actually watch this [ __ ]
on TV but until then we're stuck this is
a good start though yeah yeah we're
we're trying to learn teleportation yeah
well they've actually successfully done
that they've teleported beams of light
as well but so far again you can't put a
guy in a basket and [ __ ] teleport him
to like Florida yeah so that's kind of
boring but didn't Willy Wonka already
come up with the whole [ __ ] beam them
into the TV shows a glass elevator
that was horizontal elevator right
enough no but that no they had the
chocolate where they made the chocolate
and they put it into the
into the chocolate out of your TV it's
teleporting all right oh the particles
yeah
you're right yeah we need a blast that
guy too in the face of God you know what
I mean yeah can't be messing with that
sky and it's like that do you guys ever
think about how you know there's like a
meme about how I was born too early to
explore the stars and [ __ ] like that you
ever think about.com yeah cause
sometimes I'm like oh this generation's
so sick
I was born too early yeah you know but
you won't get to explore the Stars oh
right right kids are probably or their
grandkids will be Interstellar space
doing them [ __ ] around yeah like
Guardians I just think girls are way
more hotter now way hotter that's true I
look at pictures of presidents wives and
I'm like oh goes I'm like good on that
I'm like everyone was jumping on man
though Jackie yo was hot she was the
only one though you're right but like
everybody was fighting for her yeah
everybody yeah that's why as soon as JFK
died people pounce
hey who killed JFK though CIA probably
who doesn't think that does anyone not
think that I thought that was a mafia
I think that because of his bro head
because of Jack Ruby yeah because it
broke no his brother because his brother
got an assassination attempted or did he
get he was assassinated yeah and that
was that was the mob
we know that well I think that you know
why
the whole prohibition chair right he was
trying he's set up they [ __ ] bit the
hand that fed him yeah
or like not uh they're uh what's not
Scotch the [ __ ] Irish Bootleggers
they're but yeah moonshine oh [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] ripping off Blockbuster
videos all right I'm in on this then
[ __ ] that they were they were um they
were running that [ __ ] and they made a
[ __ ] ton of money their their dad or
grandfather right they made a lot of
[ __ ] money so they were friends with
the mob and the mob was deep with the
unions and then so like they're like all
right let's let's link up once they got
into office you know he got people with
Bobby in the the head of the FBI yeah he
was the attorney general and then they
said you know what I think there's just
too much organized crime
and then they went down whatever
whatever whatever and I think that's who
was like well [ __ ] you guys
you [ __ ] turn your [ __ ] backs on
us and we got you voted in that's a
quote so it could be that it could be
CIA I don't know leave the pause too
that's one of the theories though Mafia
is probably gonna do Joe documentaries
what we do we just get a bunch of stock
footage and [ __ ] and then we have Joe be
like yeah like I think this is like
[ __ ] I think this is North Korea and
then
you know how Jake was here the other day
so he has sick ass documentary here yeah
I should just download what he has take
the sound out [ __ ] man and I'll
voice over too 25 minutes yes I'll be
like man this [ __ ] right here I
don't know is maybe I think it's Bobby's
uh or or Rachel Kennedy I don't know
like one of them one of them and then uh
they're just walking down a street and
[ __ ] I think somebody tried to kill him
um oh yeah on this picture is what Joe
gets sidetracked on a minor detail and
then he ends up talking about feudal
Japan for like the next 18 years so
stock footage of Washington DC and like
the Kennedys and it just keeps rolling
and Joe's just talking about how the
samurai like you used to braid their
hair in a certain way
and they're like you know Tom Cruise is
actually based on real story you know
everyone's mad about the last time
like we're talking about the
assassination oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so about the Kennedys
foreign
[Music]
[Music]